Oh
all right let's do it can people hear me
oh yeah my mic is that's weird hmm oh
there it is all right the weird it's
alright if people can hear me that's
good we got so much stuff to talk about
today oh I didn't even realize this was
already on screen right yeah I forgot
about that so I don't even know where to
start because number one if you just saw
my YouTube upload from a few minutes ago
you might have seen that Facebook and
CNN shut me down yesterday and very
weird in different ways related to the
livestream that we were doing and other
things and I'm gonna have some more time
to go into it here on the stream so I
think that this will be good I want to
talk about so this is a post about
Donald Trump again appearing to be on
something during yesterday's press
conference one and I actually pulled up
the video so we can maybe try to see if
he does seem to be on uppers or coming
down from uppers or whatever the case
may be so we'll see about that but yeah
this is something we've been following
the Trump on drugs and as you see very
very dilated pupils there despite it
being very bright it's you know very
very bright so we've got that we have
this news which whoa we're dad we have
this news that the one major piece of
new testimony new evidence yesterday
from the impeachment hearing has now
been corroborated by a second embassy
staffer which is absolutely fascinating
so we're going to talk about that I have
some really funny video from Judge
Andrew Napolitano a rare occasion
occasional voice of reason on Fox News
he just makes the Fox and Friends I
believe this was on Fox and Friends yes
the Fox and Friends people visibly
deflated because they just are
disappointed that it seems that Trump
did do things that are not good
essentially so we're gonna talk about
that someone had the idea last stream
that I should go back to one of my
really early videos and watch it and see
if I still agree with what I say in it
so I picked the video from the first
week actually this is from our September
11 2009 show we're gonna take a look at
that a little
later today I may do some games of chess
potentially we will see about opening up
the phone lines we do have a target of
10 new members to open up the phone
lines and it would really be my pleasure
to do it and then yes we will be
streaming tomorrow on YouTube so
yesterday we did like a six hour stream
of the impeachment hearings and it was
extraordinarily successful the video
clip after being uploaded has about a
hundred thousand views on YouTube we add
six to seven thousand live concurrent
viewers for the full seven hours so
we're going to do it again tomorrow
starting at 10 a.m. and yes I am wearing
my bathrobe in case people are wondering
I'm getting ready getting ready to go to
bed um let's see oh I'll answer one
question David have you seen some of the
negative feedback on the Bolivia video
anecdotally I have and I don't care I
know that when I get into Latin American
politics that I will have a lot of
people furious with me but I don't care
yeah just I got to do the stories the
way I do them and I'm not going to I
just have to do I just have to do what
I'm doing you know and it's it's no big
deal and tomorrow by the way the lead
story on my show tomorrow is also about
Bolivia and it's probably one that will
piss off everybody who was happy with
the clip from a couple of days ago so
you know that's what it's gonna be by
the way I'm kidding I'm not wearing a
bathrobe and I'm not going to bed but
sometimes you know when you do this
stuff all the time sometimes you get
bored with just doing it the normal way
so I actually thought today let me wear
something and see how long it takes
people on stream to comment on it and it
took about a minute so anyway that's how
I have fun for myself let me turn my
phone down it is blowing up and P I'm
going to be traveling at the end of the
year and I have a number of people who
are coordinating travel to be at the
same place at the same time which is
exciting and they have a lot to say to
me but I'm gonna silence that we're
gonna deal with that much much later oh
and then also I have a bunch of actually
let me just do this first so I posted
this just as a goof to my
Instagram today David Pakman and by the
way if you're not following me on
Instagram you really should be a David
Pakman and I encourage you to do it and
it's just it's just a joke it's me
taking notes for today's show and I have
a notepad in front of me that has
politics misspelled okay that's the it's
just a joke that's all it is there's no
big deal but immediately people started
turning this into a meme by replacing
what is what I'm writing with other
things many of which are funny and I'm
collecting the funniest ones and I'll do
something with them next week so please
because this is twitch I feel obligated
to mention please generate memes this
picture you can find it's on my
Instagram at David Pakman and email me
the memes david at david pakman.com and
we'll see what comes of it my prediction
is that the people on twitch may come up
with much more clever memes than some of
the ones that have been coming in so far
no offense to everybody else so well
that's out of the way and then
eventually I am gonna get to some of
this um CNN stuff that's going on which
is really crazy we'll just leave that
there so thank you to urge hardcore for
subscribing for one month at tier-one
and thanks to l-3 dixon for subscribing
for four months with twitch prime i
really appreciate that
and thanks to Musashi sue for cheering
100 bits which I very much appreciate as
well
I'll make sure so I I can't thank people
who just follow me on Twitch because too
many happened during the stream and it
would interrupt it but any cheers I will
try to mention and certainly twitch
prime subs and twitch subs we will be I
will be thanking and of course anybody
who signs up on my website as well our
target is 10 the info is there let's get
right into it because there's so much to
cover so listen starting with this
picture I have been talking about the
reality that there is clearly something
wrong with the president for a very long
time now I don't know if it's cognitive
decline I don't know if it's drug abuse
but there's the picture of Trump at his
desk in Trump Tower with a bunch of
sudafed boxes over his left shoulder in
the
and it's a version of sudafed that you
can't get in the United States the
packaging it's more sudafed than you
would legally be allowed to buy and one
go in the United States and Trump very
often seems to be on uppers and then at
other times he seems to be on Downers
and we've seen that before and a couple
of the things that we've seen frequently
our number one very dilated pupils from
Donald Trump when the lighting is
brightest pupils really should should be
contracted not dilated and also we have
seen the version of Trump that is slow
and slurring and you know saying things
like god bless the United States of
America and you know Shirou Shalom
Israel and all that type of stuff but
then sometimes it's upper Trump who
seems very very high energy so anyway
somebody sent this tweet to me pointing
out that yesterday it's completely uh I
think it is something worth speculating
on actually and a number of medical
professionals have gotten in touch
saying they completely agree let's just
take a quick look at the press
conference that this purports to be from
and of course I've forgotten to plug in
my headphones but I will do that now and
we will take a look at that thanks to DJ
gibster for subscribing for the second
month with twitch Prime and thanks to aj
Scorpia 11:07 for subscribing at Tier
one and thanks Cathy 61 for cheering a
hundred bits I appreciate them let me
turn this down so I don't blow out an
eardrum there we go okay let's just take
a little bit of a look at this and see
if we notice whether it's up or down or
trump or whatever's going on and we had
a wonderful and very productive meeting
before we start I would like to thank
president erawan for so there is no
facing detainee sir can go gay who was
in detention and different forms of
detention and I appreciate that watch
that was a very nice tribute and he'll
be coming back at some point in the
not-too-distant future so that's that's
very good news for
this seems like down now here's the
thing I don't know enough about uppers
downers all this other stuff if you are
coming down from uppers would your eyes
still be extremely dilated even in high
light situations because understand that
right above here let me see if I can
signal it with my mouse I assume that
right up here there are lights to light
this properly for television and I don't
understand why your eyes would not be
contracted there okay so even during the
comedown you would potentially have
dilated pupils okay Turkey as everyone
knows is a great NATO ally and a
strategic partner of the United States
around the world our economic
relationship has tremendous potential
now let me ask another thing if you
snort sudafed and then you're coming
down from it sudafed of course is a
nasal decongestant if you're using it if
you're snorting it as Trump has been
accused of doing by people who were
behind the scenes with him on the on the
apprentice is there a rebound congestion
that happens because I'm just thinking
if you if if the effect of something
that's supposed to clear your nose goes
away what is it possible cuz Trump's son
sounds stuffed up as well that's
interesting to people saying yeah used
to expand and to grow people in the chat
know a lot about drugs
let's see between our nation's are
essential to ensuring a future of peace
and prosperity and promise for our
citizens over the course of the day
president heroin and I had a frank and
productive conversation on he is doing
the thing where he seems confused by
what he's reading but I don't think that
that's unique to the drugs a range of
very important topics among the
situation in Syria last month I sent
vice president pence Secretary of State
Pompeo is with US national security
adviser O'Brien thank you that was a
weird did anybody hear that strange
motion in Syria last month I sent vice
president pence Secretary of State
Pompeo is with US national
the advisor O'Brien thank you yeah I'm
hoping other people are hearing that
that was a very strange thing going on
so listen I don't know I don't think
this is conclusive people saying Trump's
dentures or loose he claims not to wear
dentures and and rich people tend not to
have dentures they get implants or
veneers or you know whatever the case
may be so yeah I don't know I mean
listen it it seems to me that this is a
combination of may be some slight
cognitive decline and that there seems
to be something very strange going on
here so you know will we ever know for
sure I don't know
but certainly I mean it is it is very
very odd the pupil dilation in very
bright light circumstances and it's
something that we've talked about before
and of course for people saying he might
have a cold well he might have had a
cold yesterday but we've been seeing
this for you know basically two years
straight so I don't know I don't know
what to tell you as far as that goes
okay one of the big pieces of news that
came out yesterday during after the
impeachment hearings was that William
Taylor asserted that so okay there were
a whole bunch of things that William
Taylor said in private testimony behind
closed doors and that then he repeated
yesterday but during his opening
statement yesterday William Taylor said
that one of his staff overheard a phone
call in a restaurant involving on on one
end
EU Ambassador Gordon Sunland on the
other end Trump and that during that
phone call Trump was very concerned with
when will the investigation smears into
Joe Biden start and we now have a report
that a second embassy staffer overheard
that call so again corroboration to
Embassy staffers in Kiev as I used to
pronounce at Kiev but yesterday
apparently it's pronounced Keith to
Embassy staffers in keeve not just one
overheard a phone call in which
President Donald Trump asked sunland
about the investigations acting Ukraine
ambassador Bill Taylor made the
bombshell revelation yesterday that a
day after the now infamous phone call
that's the July 25 phone call in
Trump pressured Ukrainian president is a
lense key for political politicized
investigations Trump called sunland to
ask about those investigations the
member of my staff could hear President
Trump on the phone asking ambassador
Sunland about the investigations
ambassador Sunland told President Trump
that the Ukrainians were ready to move
forward the staffer was later identified
as David Holmes the second witness to
the call was another embassy staffer
surya giyanti citing an unnamed person
briefed in the discussion so listen
everything is being corroborated and the
right wants to focus exclusively on the
whistleblower and is the whistleblower
for or against Trump and did the
whistleblower you know the was the
whistleblower in touch with this person
or that person and in reality it doesn't
matter because the whistleblower the
whistleblowers assertions have been
corroborated widely now by Gordon
Sunland by Lieutenant Colonel Alexander
VIN Minh so it's it's effectively
irrelevant at this point in time it's a
red herring it's a distraction it's a
straw man call it whatever you want and
so this is yet another example where
immediately you know I pointed out in a
segment on the broadcast show today the
big revelation yesterday was this new
assertion from William Taylor about the
phone call overheard between Sunland and
Trump well that's just hearsay well we
now have more hearsay as the Republicans
would like to say we have a second
corroboration about this phone call
getting a couple of questions here I
want to watch your hearings on on the
hearing stream on YouTube how do I find
it you go so at 10 a.m. tomorrow Eastern
Time go to youtube.com slash the david
pakman show and it should say that we
are live there let's see what else did I
watch the episode of the useful idiots
podcast with the ex-cia guy no I've
never heard of that podcast and I I've
not seen that but it sounds interesting
9:00 a.m. central yes indeed for people
asking about about that I want to say
thanks to Nathan Fleck nathan fleck is
opening up the party tonight with a
website membership
number one of ten and if we get to ten
I'll open the phone line so thanks so
much I appreciate that Nathan Nathan
Fleck signing up using the coupon code
half 19 so that's actually like a secret
coupon code so the official coupon code
is the one right over here this is
twenty twenty that's a forty percent
coupon code the secret coupon code is
half nineteen which saves you fifty
percent you're not even supposed to
mention that Nathan but I guess I made a
mistake here okay let me go to the next
thing so we've got some clips here from
Fox & Friends
now andrew napolitano is a guy who
former judge and fox news legal analyst
and he's an occasional voice of reason
he will sometimes on fox news he's more
of a libertarian guy but sometimes right
libertarians and left social
libertarians which I consider myself to
be will overlap on issues and agree
about something and in this case
recently Andrew Napolitano has been
simply telling the unvarnished truth
about Donald Trump and he went on fox
and friends and they were visibly
deflated by what Andrew Napolitano said
let's take a look at this first clips on
opinion and hearsay when you read the
transcript everyone has their own
opinion well everybody does have their
own opinion but if you look at the big
picture of that doesn't seem to be any
dispute but that the president wanted
dirt on Biden and the president was
willing to hold it up military aid in
order to get judge I how about this
legally not emotionally the president is
concerned so isn't that there it is
Brian Kilmeade desperate desperate to
reframe the narrative about what Ukraine
did in the 2016 election and it was
proven yesterday that he had every
reason to be concerned because of
because of the Biden's role supervising
Ukraine aid and hunter Biden's
legitimately perplexing place on the
number one most corrupt oil and gas
company incorporation in that country
that's a very good argument and and the
purpose of yesterday is to change
people's minds I don't think it changed
people's minds I mean I watched it all
day like like everybody else did I've
already said and
in my opinion the the law is not on the
president's side because the law says
asking for a campaign favor whether it
whether it arise of a previous election
that depends on how you look at it are
they investigating 2016 or does he want
dirt on Biden as it to as prophylactic
your 2012 three on one and they still
can't make any sense let's go let's
continue here and in this clip I believe
what we're going to see in this clip let
me see Ainsley Earhardt argues it's not
quid pro quo because Ukraine never felt
pressure and they got the eight anyway
yeah so this Andrew Napolitano is right
the delay is the quid pro quo for pro
quo we're going to watch it I prefer to
call it bribery not quid pro quo it's
easier to pronounce and also more
precise but more importantly if you
attempt to commit a crime and you just
happen to fail that doesn't exculpate
you of any liability let's take a listen
the ukrainian President did never feel
pressure and he got his money do we ever
know if he turned over anything about
Biden did the president apparently he
did whatever this is the worst shakedown
ever yeah the delay is the quid pro quo
charge a delay of fifty five days
knowing that the Russians were at the
board but if you didn't know a direct
deposit didn't land look 2020 the
Ukrainian president didn't okay so
that's that one and then let's I don't
know it comes down to saying we're
talking about Congress this is not a
court of law
yes this is essentially a TV show people
were waiting for a smoking gun yesterday
and ultimately it looks like it's baked
into the cake that they're going to
impeach him because you impeach somebody
of high crimes and misdemeanors and that
can be anything they say it is yes
remember President Ford an impeachable
offenses whatever the house of
representatives says it is this is
political
it is not juridical the rules of court
do not apply hearsay is as valid and
politically potent as direct test they
have never here's what it yeah I'm sure
Steve do she is about to say he never
he's never heard of he's never heard of
something that he hasn't heard of but is
still completely relevant let's see what
a lot of people saying a lot of things
while that was going on
what do I think of the critique that
these officials opinion on Trump's
foreign policy shouldn't override Trump
since these are elected president yeah
this isn't about policy that that's the
thing this is this is about bribery it's
not about policy so not not not the the
it's it's an it's an argument for
something different altogether let me
say thank you to Morten ID
Ida ID I'm I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly Morten is new member number
two of the evening new member number two
memberships up there counted tallied our
memberships on join pakman.com just so
people know and we don't have any
confusion this evening we wouldn't want
that okay next here's an idea from the
last twitch stream I listened to you
guys see I do listen and no I'm not
wearing a bathrobe for people that keep
asking about that but I mentioned
earlier in the stream merely is a joke
because sometimes I just get bored and I
want to do something differently I
looked in my closet and I said what can
I put on that will trigger people to
immediately talk about what I'm wearing
instead of what I'm saying and I picked
this and I put it on and I think 30
seconds and people were talking about it
but it is not a bathrobe but it's just a
I don't even know what to call it it's a
sweatshirt of some kind
it's a sweatshirt I don't know okay last
stream or the stream before a bunch of
people said David you should go back to
an old video watch it and then see if
you agree with what you said or just
what you think about it so let's do it I
went back and now here's the thing I'm
sure there are far more interesting
videos than this one this video is from
10 years ago more than 10 years ago can
you imagine by the way more than 10
years ago and our best day on YouTube
was two days ago can you can you just
imagine that trajectory it's stunning
let's just see what I said from what I
previewed the first 15 seconds because
it starts kind of in a weird place when
the video starts we are listening to I
believe it is Joel Osteen then on the
Larry King show Joel Osteen is this
evangelical preacher getting confronted
about our Jews going to hell or aren't
they going to hell and Joel Osteen
always tries to play it's funny I
remember the segment doing it 10 years
ago Joel Osteen always likes to print
play the non-judgmental Christian but
when it gets right down to it the caller
if I recall correctly kind of pushes him
to have to say well can Jews go to
heaven or can't Jews go to heaven this
is the first studio we ever had this was
a shared studio I'll tell you a few
stories
listen we have time let's I'll tell you
a few stories about this this was the
first studio we ever had this was at
Valley free radio in Northampton
Massachusetts call letters WX o J and I
would literally record the show on my
laptop this is my old Dell Latitude or
Inspiron that's over over my shoulder
and I would record it and I just added
it to the to the imagery by having the
waveform going the tube that you see in
the back here this was we were in a
basement this was one of those modular
air conditioners the air conditioner is
this silver thing I remember it like
it's just yesterday and it vents out the
air conditioner was too loud to run
while we were filming but it was so hot
in the studio that we would take breaks
where I would play songs and run it for
five minutes
and then come back we had this
vertically oriented mixer which often
didn't work and there was always like a
battle people who didn't understand
signal flow which I didn't at the time
would be basically fight like the mixer
that that's down here the main board
that my hands are operating would be
fighting the signal level up on this it
was just a mess this the signal to noise
ratio was all messed up there was also a
fan which you can see down in the bottom
left corner which there were people who
were convinced okay you can't run the AC
while you're on the air but you can run
the fan but the fan was pointed directly
at the microphones and you could not you
you couldn't if you wanted to produce
anything approximating a quality show
you could not run any of this equipment
so it was like a hundred degrees okay
let's now together listen to this
segment from ten years ago on the David
Pakman show you're the best and thank
you all for your positive messages and
your book
I'm wondering though why you sidestep
larry's earlier question about how we
get to heaven the Bible clearly tells us
that Jesus is the way the truth and the
light and the only way to the father is
through him that's not really a message
of condemnation but of truth yeah I
would agree with her I believe that is
what you is not going away
no I well here's my thing there is I
can't judge somebody's heart you know I
don't know only God can look at
somebody's heart and so I don't know I
just to me it's not my business to say
you know this one is or this one isn't
I'm just saying here's what the Bible
teaches and I want to put my faith what
a cop you know in Christ and I just I
think it's wrong when we go around
saying you know you're not going you're
not going you're not going because it's
not exactly my way I'm just I'm not
going to be your way I believe my way
I believe my way with all my heart that
there's someone who doesn't share it we
always wrong and yeah and well I don't
know if I look at it like that I would I
would present my way but I'm just going
God be the judge of that you know I
don't know so you make no judgment on
anyone no but I'll probably theists you
know I just you know what Holly ilex um
all right so he goes around in circles I
mean it's how good Larry King asked it
any more clearly so what you're telling
me is a Jew doesn't go to heaven no I'm
not saying that I'm saying that you know
my way is the right way and there's
other ways but it's not on me to judge
about the other ways this guy's is in a
very literally I'm not even being
sarcastic in a very astute way avoiding
answering that other people who don't
subscribe to his way which he believes
is the way and by the way speaking of
way what was I doing
wearing a crewneck undershirt with a
v-neck polo right I mean that I that is
not something I would ever be caught
doing a gun in the true way that they're
going to hell
I like how he says I don't know though
you know if you could interpret that
different ways but to me that made it
sound like you know he doesn't know 100%
for sure what happens when you die
but he did say I'm sure that my way is
the way well he says you know I put my
faith in the Bible and I believe that
that's the way but he doesn't I mean you
don't really know until
the end I guess well it's it's a he's a
fascinating guy and if you take a look
at some find a lot of similarities
between him and Michael Jackson and
their demeanor in terms of the way they
talk so on and so forth
hey here's a quick video of Al Franken
talking down talking down an angry mob
at the state fair in Minnesota dorsum
anti health reformers came up to him
Lewis looking at always the latest poll
the people Minnesota
all right we can barely even hear it
because it sounds like he's doing the
the it sounds like he's doing this
little press conference literally as a
concert is going on he might even he
might even be on stage to be completely
honest during the concert he does a
great job he has about 12 people who
don't want health care reform gather
around him he diffuses it he even tells
some stories that bring a few people to
tears I'm telling you Al Franken is
growing on me as a senator first I
thought it was funny just because it
irritated Bill O'Reilly but he really
does seem to be somewhat competent a bad
point he's a very very smart man well
you know Bill O'Reilly would not agree
last thing today Charlie Rangel is
really not looking good congressman
Charlie Rangel recently filed
disclosures that show he failed to
report about half a million dollars in
assets in oh seven it also shows that
his net worth is between one and 2.5
million or twice what he claimed in Oh 8
even worse though is that since since
ethics probes began last year the
congressman has given campaign donations
to 119 members of Congress including
three of the five Democrats on the House
Ethics Committee all right so I think
this certainly the David Pakman show has
improved since these days there's a
reason that this clip only has two
thousand views and now most of our
videos get two thousand views in the
first ten minutes after we published
them but I think it's interesting to go
back and see this this iteration so to
speak of the David Pakman show
now I could probably I if I if I'd been
more prepared I could have also found
something from like each iteration of
the show including some of the weird in
between studios that we have but I
figured I would just try this one see if
people are interested in it and we can I
mean may I should really take
suggestions from other people about what
old clips we should go back and look at
but certainly you know a lot of things
have changed since then my hair looks
very different my clothing has
drastically changed the the you know
production value of the program has
drastically changed you know I don't
know what else many many things have
changed and that's an it that's
important change is good
fried sickled has subscribed for three
months with twitch prime and I really
appreciate that with the message hi from
Philly thank you so much I also want to
say thanks to Jesse deal elo
who has signed up on my website becoming
new member number 3 of 10 3 of 10 for
opening up the phone lines and 3 of 24a
guaranteeing another stream this week
this is the third twitch stream this
week so it would be a big accomplishment
people continuing to ask if I'm wearing
a bathrobe I am NOT I am not wearing a
bathrobe bathrobe and people asking why
I don't have any blinds I do they're
just not down but I do have I do have
blinds let's see here do we have
anything else at some point I'm going to
jump into the the Facebook CNN stuff
it's just it is a [ __ ] show so I'm kind
of like working up to it because it's
you know it's it's it's it's
extraordinary flustered frustrating oh
if there's peeping toms that would be
weird I'm on the tenth floor so that
would be very strange all right I guess
we just maybe jump into it well let me
see what this is David have you seen
this laura ingraham segment about how
much water George Kent drank during the
hearing and the fact that one of the
Democratic Congress women had a paper
clip stuck in her hair you know what I I
do want to see that I actually want to
see that before we move on laura
ingraham kent water let's see
hmm the computer just totally froze
there that was weird
nothing it's on Twitter okay let me see
if I can find it let's see Laura Ingram
george kent water twitter
let's see foxnews stunned that
impeachment witness drank water this
seems this seems good let's take a look
at this
alright let me see if I couldn't find it
here here we go
water Lauder Laura
I mean fish are not this hydrated look
he's always taking [ __ ] look throughout
the hearing took slugs it's amazing it
was like a medical sighs what is a
medical amount of water good that may
actually be one of the funniest things
I've ever heard he was drinking medical
quantities this may be the stupidest
thing that I've ever seen on fox news I
have to watch it a medical quantity of
water he drank a lot of water Lauder
Laura I mean not this hydrated look he's
always taking [ __ ] look throughout the
hearing took slugs is he on the
treadmill it's amazing it's like a
medical side I have to say I hope you
you guys will all just excuse me for a
moment I have to send a tweet about this
because it's just so crazy please
retweet this I'm about to tweet this
help me help me workshop a tweet about
this on my at D Pakman account and then
let's all retweet it and see what we can
do I'm gonna I'll write it the first
time and then let me know how you would
change it Fox News criticizing
impeachment witness for drinking what
some dude claims is a medical amount of
water
what is a medical amount of water is
that I mean any other better ideas
medical size is a unit of measurement
workshop the tweet for me to make it
more clever because I'm terrible on
Twitter I'm David Pakman and I'm wearing
a bathrobe here's a video that's not I
could go with that that I could
certainly go with that instead just post
the video and write anyone remember
Brett Fox Newt gets wet Fox News gets
wet over Kent's water drink that's not
bad
all right I'm just gonna tweet it the
way I have it please retweet it let's
see how many retweets we can get on this
on this thing in short order I'm at Deep
hackman on Twitter and I just tweeted it
by the way I just updated my picture to
this here it is let's watch it in real
time let's see if we get if retweets
happen in real time oh yeah they are
happening in real time interesting two
three I'm just gonna count no I'm not
really gonna do that how am I using
light mode on Twitter I don't know how
to change it I'm a Boomer I've been told
Kent destroys liberal thirst with
excessive water hmm is this more or less
important than Obama's tan suit I need
to know make sure you use the word
slammed I think yeah referring to taking
slugs of water can you imagine all right
dark mode more than dark mode more
actually just in case that pulls up
something very weird oh it doesn't
display dim or lights out I guess I'll
go with lights out okay all right we're
back whoa here it is all right we did it
I fixed it for you guys all right I
think we got it 26 retweets not not not
bad I mean that happened pretty quickly
all right I'll leave this up okay so I'm
gonna I'm going to now go into oh wait a
second no I have to
some people first thank you - Lars Borno
for signing up on my website that is new
member 4 of 10 if we get to 10 I will
open up the phone lines for you fine
folks
Lars born oh thank you so much thanks
also to zoo 'pl 92 for subscribing with
twitch prime I appreciate that very much
ok alright so let's get let's get into
this this it's just it's almost painful
to talk about so let me let me explain
what would happen so two months ago I
did a livestream of a democratic debate
that aired on CNN and I started that
livestream on YouTube and two minutes
into the event CNN gave me a copyright
strike on YouTube and shut me down and I
went over to twitch and I streamed it
was actually my first evening on Twitch
i streamed the rest of that debate on
Twitch and it did really well we got
like I don't know like 500 twitch subs
and it was crazy things were coming off
the wall the entire building was shaking
cuz things were going so crazy on Twitch
so two months went by and I think that
got us to like laughs a few weeks ago
whenever the last debate was and I just
started up the debate coverage on Twitch
instead of even doing the YouTube thing
at all
and CNN shut me down on twitch they gave
me you know a DMCA on twitch okay so
when we started thinking about doing
live coverage of the impeachment
hearings yesterday I made sure that you
know House proceedings are public domain
are taxpayer dollars fund government and
the salaries of the people who are
issuing the subpoenas and everything
else and I made sure that there would be
a video feed from the House of
Representatives and c-span and I don't
have to restream CNN or Fox News or
anybody I'm in the clear it's gonna be
great
so we do the entire livestream we
started it about 9:40 in the morning
when until 4:15 p.m.
six and a half hour livestream in
addition to that I left and went to the
studio did the show the broadcast show
and then came back it was an insane day
right I mean we had every but everybody
was working it was an all-hands-on-deck
day and we produced what was it pretty
good so you know six and a half hour
livestream we took phone calls and all
of this stuff
so about 20 minutes after the live
stream ends YouTube goes through its
process and it archives the video so
that people can go back and watch it
later and within a few minutes I get
this email from YouTube this email says
let me zoom it in a little bit for you
this email says david pakman show live
Trump impeachment hearing day one bill
Taylor and George Kent received a
third-party claim from Turner CNN live
CID click here to review and if
necessary take action on the claim the
YouTube team now CNN filed a claim on my
content even though I didn't use
anything of theirs right I did a stream
that was six and a half hours long and
we had you know five and a half hours of
a house video and then I think I had 10
minutes of something like you know I
think I think it was actually Fox News
or NBC running this press conference for
a few minutes I didn't use any CNN
content so what happens I say to myself
alright at least it's not monetized but
at least the video is still up so people
can watch it so I go to youtube and it
turns out it's not this was the status
of the Content ID claim visibility
blocked no-one can view this video
monetization obviously if the video is
blocked it's not going to earn revenue
once this was all resolved this video
got a hundred thousand views in ten or
twelve hours
imagine if it had actually been enabled
for those immediate six hours after the
hearing when more people were looking
for it
so I filed an appeal as you can see here
in the bottom right
let me zoom that in a little bit as you
can see down here it says dispute under
review by this morning the dispute had
been accepted by CNN and they removed
the copyright strike the the claim
whatever so you know people said David
it's illegal to false file false DMCA
takedowns okay what I'm gonna do sue I'm
gonna hire a lawyer over the lost
revenue for those six hours I mean yes
it's not insignificant revenue but I'm
gonna file you know a lawsuit over that
it's crazy so so this is how it all
happens where what what else can I
really do I mean I guess I can talk
about it and tell people support me
outside of the system okay so that's
number one thing that happened yesterday
now here's the other thing a year and a
half ago a year and a couple months ago
I get an email from Facebook and as many
of you know we have a Facebook page
we've been uploading to Facebook for a
long time oh people asking for the
retweets to come back on the read sweets
have slowed down keep retweeting please
keep it going I got an email from
Facebook saying congratulations you now
have the privilege of monetizing videos
that you upload to Facebook which is
great because we've been monetizing on
YouTube for a long time but we had been
uploading videos to Facebook but they
don't make any money because Facebook
didn't run ads on them so we signed up
for Facebook monetization and I had you
know all the hopes in the world but then
nothing really happened like I think the
first month we made like five bucks
all the videos you know that we uploaded
that that that month we made like five
dollars and then the next month we made
like seven dollars or something like
that and I was almost ready to give up
on Facebook monetization but lo and
behold a few months ago Facebook video
finally starts to make some money it
actually starts to make an impact on the
show's revenue so of course I'm thrilled
because YouTube being like this and
twitch being very unpredictable and up
and down I thought it was great we are
finally starting to make some money on
Facebook a few days ago I notice
we're making less money every day on
Facebook even though we're still
uploading all of our content the hell's
going on yesterday I noticed that we
made 0 for two days in a row now how is
it possible we're getting you know a
hundred thousand views a day or
something on Facebook it's not nearly as
big as YouTube but a hundred thousand
views a day is starting to add up how
could we be making 0 on on Facebook it
doesn't make any sense
so I came across this restricted
monetization your pages ability to earn
is limited because it isn't following
our partner monetization policies now
immediately I said what the hell I
haven't seen anything about this I
haven't been notified about this and
down here it says date notified November
6th the David Pakman show
shared content that was removed by
Facebook for going against our community
standards we were never notified on
Facebook I was never notified by email I
know how to check my spam folder I know
how to do all of those things we were
never notified shut down I start looking
around how do I contact Facebook they
make it impossible support no ad manager
no I find an option it's really just
this but see this blue button request
another review before it was just
request a review and I pressed it you
can't fill in any information here's
what I got back hi David thanks for
submitting an appeal after taking a look
we've decided to temporarily suspend
monetization because your page goes
against our content policies to avoid
suspension look at our standards
you must also follow intellectual
property you can check this Facebook
site to see if we contacted you you
click on that it's a generic support
site there's nothing there there's no
messages in from Facebook at all
so I say because it is signed Mitchell I
think oh it's a real person
I can hit reply and Mitchell is going to
take care of this for me I reply and I
say I was never notified please tell me
what piece of content but a little bit
and as you can see I got this at 6:52
p.m. right 652 p.m. I immediately reply
659 p.m. I get this back thank you for
contacting us your previous request has
been closed and we will not be able to
see your response please submit a new
request so there's no actual way to
figure out what piece of content it was
that was responsible for shutting down
this entire thing so when people wonder
you know why is it that we promote stuff
like membership on join pakman.com it's
because of this [ __ ] because
ultimately all I can do is diversify our
sources of revenue so we've got
membership and YouTube and twitch and
Amazon affiliate and Facebook and
whatever but then at any point you know
anybody who wants to shut you down so
that that's the reason for that that is
basically that's a lure detailed version
of the story that I told on the
broadcast show today
Thank You page by the way for commenting
here David I want to drink a medical
amount of your bathwater
very much appreciated Martin ID who is a
new member says enable bttv emotes
please luciano Rubino the amount of
doctor usually drinks the hard-hitting
and in-depth analysis Fox is known for
they were joking libs can't take a joke
as usual by the way the Chiron wasn't
about the water that was a big bottle of
water okay
great let me just I want to listen to it
one more time he's always taking [ __ ]
look throughout the hearing took slugs
was he on the treadmill it's amazing
it's like a medical side that's just so
crazy if you're supposed to drink eight
glasses of water a day what does it mean
to call it a medical amount I still I
just I just don't know okay let me say
thanks to a couple of other people thank
you too
okay hold on Andrew Thompson is a new
member on my website thank you so much
Andrew Mary Reardon Burgess or Burgas
Burgess
I sound like Jessica Lee Peterson he had
been Burgess on and he wasn't sure how
to pronounce it I don't know how to
pronounce this Mary Riordan Burgess
thank you so much
David wohl yay thank you for becoming a
new member I appreciate that Quinlan
Matthews has signed up on my website
that is number four and okay that's it
that gets us to eight eight of ten
website members eight of twenty website
members to trigger another stream talk
to destiny right now David I haven't
talked to destiny for a while let's see
maybe I will only because I haven't done
this recently when people have suggested
it but I've not talked to him for a
while so I want to take a look at maybe
what's going on let's see here
I haven't even loaded discord for so
long that it's updating let's see here
okay is destiny on Raj hold on where are
my friends on here all it this says
destiny is offline so let's see hey are
you there according to this destiny is
not online
oh okay so people people aren't even
saying destiny is online they're just
saying talk to destiny alright well if
he's not online that I can't do it oh
he's there oh wow that's so funny
oh hey are you streaming people are
telling me to chat with you on my stream
but aren't you on vacation I think I got
trolled destiny is online people are
saying
hmm oh he is streaming that's kinda
that's interesting yeah we can chat just
call away all right let's do it let's
call destiny start voice call here we go
can't hear a thing though Steve even now
very myself oh wait did something hmm
can you hear me oh hey yeah I'm doing
great Deepak how are you done my own
voice is feeding back to me on like a
half second delay them alright hello
hello it still happened you sound like
you're underwater all soccer balls
you're not using bluetooth are you wait
can you do facebook Messenger
yeah I do I don't know if we're friends
on there let me see I'll try calling
hold on stay on wait me just until I see
a vet friend are you Steven destiny
Bunnell ii on facebook okay yeah I'm
gonna hang up on discord I don't call
you on there okay man discord is just
toxic today
let's see start a voice call okay here
we go
Yeti alright oh shut up hello hello is
that feedbacking hair is it okay no it
sounds fine yeah okay is better than
just bird alright what do you want to
talk about my good friend so are you in
Moscow Idaho Idaho yeah
I know yeah why yo yeah that's one of
them one of my first radio affiliates is
what are your fur yo Philly it's no [ __ ]
that's awesome
yeah it's like W RFP or something like
that W RFP okay do you know that radio
station who knows
oh well what you want to chat about so I
don't know I I like we haven't checked
in for a little while and my my audience
is telling me that like there's a lot of
crazy stuff going on with you like you
you're not getting along with some of
the people in our circles and stuff
oh dude I am totally out of all that
[ __ ] I [ __ ] hate online lefties my
dude I'm sorry how are you do they drive
me crazy man I can't I just can't
[ __ ] do it anyway it's as bad as when
I was like debating like all writers
like these people are insane to be clear
when I say lefty I'm specifically
referring to like be hardcore like
socialists and communists like I still
consider myself like really progressive
and I like like left-leaning people but
like the actually if I say anti-liberal
do you know what I mean by that like
auntie like liberalism like those types
of like well so the term I've been using
and I'm wondering if you're talking
about the same group I call it the
revolutionary left sure we can call it
that I guess there's like a million
different labels for like every group
now so I don't know but it's possible
with that yeah these are these are like
the hardcore justice dem supporters or
like the big like Bernie supporters like
the very very communist socialist people
not just people that are like Social
Democrats or it over yeah oh okay yes
see I I actually I thought you meant
like a more extreme group because I
don't know most I don't think most
Bernie supporters necessarily are in
that but I know exactly the the gist of
what you're saying yeah so you're
actively fighting with people yeah I am
NOT you're right not the majority of the
Bernie supporters I would say the
majority of like the online like Reddit
and Twitter Bernie supporters are like
like there's a larger subsection of
these people than like actually like
communist and socialist not like the not
of the broader like electorate ever but
yeah these people online are just very
[ __ ] annoying the room did you have
you done any bolivia commentary cuz
that's a minefield yeah i did i wanted i
spent like a lot of my plane rides like
reading about it and i'm dude I'm like
Florida I really don't know so like I've
been trying to find out how the CIA is
involved in all of this and every time I
keep reading comments people are just
like well the CIA did it in the past so
they've probably done this one too
oh yeah I mean I
I'm having a real problem because like I
don't know if you you know I'm from
Argentina and yeah
you know we had this military
dictatorship there shortly before I was
born and there's been there's this thing
you what I'm trying to tell people in
good faith is you just have to look at
these situations a little bit
differently than just like it's a
military coup or Evo Morales is a is a
populist hero like it's just it's a
little bit more nuanced than that and
it's like you know there's a lot of
these lefties in Latin America that get
elected under populism and then they
become authoritarian or like figure out
ways to stay in power longer than they
should have but that doesn't mean that
then when they're replaced that we
replace them with anybody we like like
in this case a literal racist religious
nut lunatic carrying an oversized Bible
seize the presidency in blood let's talk
about that so because I actually take
issue someone's framing so she really
sees it right like she was literally the
next in line who is the interim
president who is supposed to be doing
new elections that's my understanding
right there she became the I think it's
more complicated than that she ended up
being next in line I I I'm doing this on
the show tomorrow so I have a lot still
to read about it but I believe that she
ended up being next in line because like
there were some other there were some
additional resignations that yes yeah
yep yeah so that is true I think I want
to say five but I could be wrong but
there were several resignations ahead of
her and then she ended up in charge yeah
I just I want to be really careful in
the framing because when you talk to
lefties the framing is literally that
the military stepped in did I hose the
current leader and then installed her
the new fascist dictator like whereas
what's really happened is a lot of
people resign that were like Morales
like supporters basically and then she
is the next in line she seems pretty
[ __ ] crazy obviously but she's only
supposed to be there she's supposed to
be there to oversee new elections that's
it she's not supposed to be the new
permanent rule or anything like that ya
know and so what we have to see is do
the elections happen and she she can't
be a candidate in those elections and if
she tries to be that's also a problem
and and you know yeah we'll just have to
wait and see yeah but the thing is this
is like this is Latin American politics
like it's happened in Venezuela
Argentina Chile Nicaragua Honduras spoke
Bolivia you get a populist who becomes
authoritarian and then you get
straight-up fascists who oppose them and
then when they say cede at pushing them
out they put in someone who's completely
bonkers in a different way yeah yeah the
problem with Morales is it like if you
look at the history of his regime
it's been overwhelmingly positive from
what I can see like he's certainly the
first leader yeah yeah he's done like a
lot of good stuff for lifting people out
of poverty and whatnot yeah she seems
like and again like I don't know I don't
I haven't read as much into it but the
guy seems like a little bit of an
egomaniac like he did really well and he
thinks he's the only one that can do it
so that's why he's like looking to push
like more terms or whatever for himself
and the way that he went about doing it
I don't know did you read the whole OS
report yes I did so here's another thing
where people like oh the OAS is like all
lying or whatever that report is pretty
damning I read the whole thing it's only
14 pages it is the claim that they
literally just made every single claim
and they're up that it's all fake or
what yeah well so the the claim that the
primary claim I've been reading is that
the report cites irregularities without
being specific
and that even irregularities are not
don't don't warrant a forced resignation
mmm so you said you read the report
right Byford yes I did yeah I mean it
was fairly specific right like it gave
like that where the vote was heading up
like with 80% of the votes counted it
showed that when the last 20% in came in
there was like that seriously massive
uptick to avoid the runoffs but the
contracts is here's the problem so there
are some people who are going too far
and saying that at a certain point when
voting was interrupted Morales was
losing and that is not true I believe
it's that he was not winning by enough
to avoid a runoff yes you know what I
mean so it's a little more complex yeah
for sure but still important right
because it seems like when that pause
happen in the counting
yes weird [ __ ] happen because when all
the new towel
came in he won like 6040 in order to
avoid that runoff which seemed a little
strange and then when they went soon
they started checking some districts and
they found out that like some districts
for instance we're recording 100% voter
turnout and that like some of the
tallies like when they tried to
cross-reference them with the names
people have voted they couldn't find
those names and that was just a little
bit of data they had access to and then
when you start reading about all the
weird [ __ ] with that that'd be of the
b20 or the vo - server whatever they
were like routing some of these votes
through servers that weren't
pre-authorized by the OAS that nobody
had accountability over it oh man I
don't know like I like the statement
like I think I would never say like
those elections were rigged but I would
say you absolutely couldn't verify the
integrity of those elections 100% and
the problem is that like there's no way
to talk about this without getting
comments like for example I'm from an
Argentine like a rich Argentinian white
family and we are all about
dictatorships and military cooze and
it's like did we left Argentina because
we had no money like what are you
talking about you know and it just
immediately devolves into character
assassination yeah what I this is
actually crazy only two people have ever
attacked me over my ethnicity my
nationality I don't know what I like
so I'm half Cuban I don't know what that
would count as but um Nick well you're a
white guy I'm very clearly [ __ ] white
call me at gusano which I didn't know
what it was for a while and I found out
that that means worm in Spanish yeah it
means that um you're like part of the
Cuban aristocracy that ran away when
Castro like tried to give all the stuff
back to the poor people or some [ __ ]
right that was the same thing that was
so what they said to me was when the
dictatorship fell my family was upset
that there was democracy so we left so
are you nuts are you is [ __ ] it feels
like some it feels like you're on the
level of like the Jewish Question [ __ ]
where people are getting like insanely
conspiratorial like what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah no it's it's bad but so but now it
does the battle are you also on bad
terms with Hassan destiny Pike or the
second we're pretty we're pretty dumb
though so you guys aren't like hanging I
just I approach politics like very
differently than a lot of these people
like I'm very interested in like well
what have
what are the facts where did they take
us whereas a lot of people seem to be
like very married to a certain ideology
and that's your big car load Morales
like the guy who is a socialist leader
part of the last of the [ __ ] pinkos
squad or some [ __ ] right like he's got a
lot of allies and other socialist
countries I think Maduro has spoken up
for him and [ __ ] he's like she's like
and he had a really successful regime so
I think lefties are just holding on to
that and they're really scared that like
Kim getting deposed means that like
either the Western world is opposing
socialism or socialism might fail where
the US is intervening again to put up to
prop up some new fascist regime or some
[ __ ] like I don't know like it's a mess
so just a couple other things that
people wanted me to ask about there's
something about the the N word in
private which maybe we don't even want
to go into because I guess I'm twitch
that's pretty dicey no it's so basically
I have a thing where i okay I have a
private public language stance okay
what I say is that um I there are jokes
that I make in private but I'm not
comfortable making publicly because I
think that is a public like performer or
whatever one would be that I have like a
responsibility to like the type of stuff
that I talk about publicly but like in
private there are a lot of like jokes
that I would say that I'm just I would
never say publicly because I don't think
it's responsible and people like raise
or focus onto that to like one like
would you use like a racial slur would
you say the end we're privately whatever
I don't know I guess it depends on the
joke whatever and then it basically like
the entire online left came together to
try to like assassinate me as like an
all right racist because I think that
like privately you can say jokes that
you shouldn't say publicly face it okay
I mean that is you might be shocked to
hear this but that is way less bad than
what my what people were telling me in
my chat you know I'm not shocked to hear
that at all I mean III to be clear I
don't use any of those words in private
but there are stories in private that I
have I've participated in that reference
you know maybe in group jokes or
whatever so I completely agree with the
idea that I'm not gonna say everything
on my show that I would say privately
but I'm completely sure I've never
accidentally or on purpose said the N
word in private like part of it is you
just never know who's listening you know
yeah sure of course
hey and then the other thing is what is
what are we watching on your channel
right now like what what are my
watching my channel wait really
what's up I'm just like hanging out with
a friend I'm in like Washington and then
you just call or I dunno so hi what's up
Dee Peck all right cool and you like the
phone up like that the entire time yeah
well I mean I can set it on my stomach
okay but yeah all right cool when are
you back in wherever it is that you say
you live when you do stuff online
um and LA I think the 18th I get home in
the 18th and then I'm moving so I hope
to be streaming again on the night of
the 19th I think are you're moving with
in LA yeah I live in Glendale and I'm
moving closer to like Venice Beach or
whatever oh I love Venice yeah yeah you
know it'd be great you should look into
one of those nice big beachfront houses
in Manhattan Beach I could see you there
is that like in Manhattan or as many no
no so in California hello
okay yeah well when I'm a millionaire
like the David Pakman show it's all go
ahead beachfront property okay oh man
all right man good to catch up with you
yeah thanks a lot have fun be careful
man all right we'll talk to you soon yep
we'll be real careful the last one I've
seen people come out with this I haven't
gotten a look into it yet apparently
there is one source that's published
like 16 audio logs of like different the
u.s. leader is saying that the CIA is
gonna overthrow have you heard about
this yet no no I haven't oh you should
look into that because that's the next
big thing that people are citing where
they're like okay here's proof I think
it was um not Telemundo tell a fund or
tell it some some some publication it's
like the only one I don't think anybody
else is like corroborated this but from
one anonymous source they're saying
they've got like 16 audio logs the
telephone may be telephone telephone
though they're saying yeah they have
like audio logs or whatever of like CIA
or us like electors here's some [ __ ]
yeah yeah you sure look I'm gonna check
that out and let me now I'll say one
more thing as well please tell your
audience to retweet my latest tweet
about one of the impeachment witnesses
drinking water that's what we're trying
to get the tweet to go viral why it's
it's it's a very long story but I'll cut
you one for free okay all right sounds
good
yeah no problem all right man I'll talk
to you soon okay I'll see you later Ben
bye all right Stephen destiny bunnell ii
very very exciting and the the retweets
continue oh let me pull that back up the
retweets continue let's just listen to
it one more time if you're just joining
us because it is so damn funny a medical
amount of water is the word of the day
he drank a lot of water Lauder Laura my
fish are not this hydrated look he's
always taking [ __ ] look throughout the
hearing took slugs it's amazing it's
like a medical side it's just so stupid
it's like it's a medical amount of
granny smith apples really what is the
medical dose of that wouldn't how much
of that would that be oh [ __ ] destinies
of people are coming in like 70 retweets
right away that is funny
132 it is climbing and people are liking
this first response from Paige David I
want to drink a medical amount of your
bath water very very racy okay let me
thank a few other people Christina Ross
thank you for signing up on my website
Catherine and nagito Robbie or Naga -
Robbie thank you so much for signing up
on my website oh that's it okay two
people and that gets us to ten which
means we will be opening up the phone
lines for a little bit very exciting
we'll do that shortly that's the
secondary goal of twenty is if we get to
twenty new members I'll do another
stream this week this is already stream
number three I normally do one or two so
things could get very crazy let me also
say thanks to some people who have been
doing stuff on Twitch
let's see wind / wings cheered a hundred
bits which I appreciate X socks
subscribe for two months with prime
thank you wind / wings sent another
hundred bits
gaius baltar 2017 that's the doctor from
Battlestar Wright subscribed with prime
wind / wings sent another five hundred
bits wookie Smith subscribed with prime
Wren VAX subscribed with prime for three
months and Kingfisher games cheered a
hundred bits
okay David look at the subreddit yeah
yeah I don't know I think I'm a little
too busy for that right now but let me
take a quick look just in case there's
anything relevant let's see here I'm not
seeing anything super interesting there
hmm okay yeah I'm not seeing anything
super relevant but okay do people want
me to take phone calls or do people want
me to talk to his son if he wants to
talk I guess I could do a straw poll but
I don't know that it's necessary I son a
lot of Hasan's stuff phone calls son no
his son
most people saying his son so I'll do
the phone calls also let me just see if
I can get him on real quick and then if
we can't then we will move on let me see
here son hey you want to check in on
stream real quick my audience is
demanding it let's see what he has to
say all right we'll see what's up with
that let's see
he's he seems to be busy isn't his son
working I don't know that means is he
streaming let me see here yeah Hasan is
streaming he is streaming alright we'll
just leave that up in the meantime let's
do some phone calls now just to get
going on that because we never know if
and when we might hear back from Hassan
so I've enabled the phone line the phone
number is six one seven eight three zero
4750 Hassan's busy watching YouTube
videos oh okay all right well I want to
bother him and so let's see I'll update
it in the description eight three zero
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let me call in myself get
started thank you for calling in to the
David Pakman show
right please do not use speakerphone
have your question ready and listen for
David to call out your area code okay I
think we're almost ready six one seven
eight three zero 4750 we are taking
phone calls let me say thank you to
William Van Vechten William Van Vechten
let me go back to the tweet and William
Van Vechten becomes new member number
eleven of the evening thank you very
much and let's see if I missed anybody
else Oh Joel Fleischer I want to thank
and Cheryl Brenner I want to thank and
Michael Crozier I want to thank and
Christina Ross I want to thank okay so I
missed a bunch of these here wait no
Christina Ross I already thinked so
that's four more all right 15 and 15 is
the number okay let's see who we can
chat with on the Oh hold on his son
we're watching something at the moment
how much longer are you on okay not sure
let me know all right there we go let's
pick up on our first caller let's go to
Keith from the six one two Keith from
the six one two
what's going on hey David how's it going
good how are you I'm wondering what you
think might happen if say Sanders gets
the nomination do you think there's
going to be any kind of third-party run
in the center huh are you from the Upper
Midwest somewhere okay I like trying to
identify accents okay
what is so what do I think is it can you
rephrase the question once more I was
just so taken with your accent that I
was distracted oh yeah so I'm wondering
if Bernie Sanders or a little bit Warren
gets the nominee I think there's a lot
of potential in the center kind of like
I sort of see like Bloomberg and Mitt
Romney as being closer alignment a
Bloomberg and Sanders I don't know that
I see any of those so okay Romney and
Bloomberg are two different things
Bloomberg has very loudly abandoned the
Republican Party and become a Democrat
so even though ideologically I don't
disagree with you that he's sort of a
less extreme flavor of Romney I think
that the implication would be
drastically different of Bloomberg
versus versus Romney and I don't know
that I see Bloomberg really making an
impact in a lot of the country he seems
like the type of guy that maybe could do
okay in some very narrow primaries
situations but I I just I know a lot of
people are talking about Bloomberg could
be the uniter I don't see it okay yeah I
guess I see the Republican Party kind of
turning into more like like a
nationalist european-style right-wing
party and so I just wonder if different
sort of two-party system might possibly
emerged oh I think that there's no doubt
that we may see the Democratic Party
move to the left and we may see a
fracturing of the Republican Party that
is really a fracturing that is in great
in a great sense catalyzed by Donald
Trump
I just don't know
you know there's a there's an approach
that says that will allow a real
centrist party to take hold but it's
like Democrats basically have been the
centrist party for a long time yeah yeah
I just wonder if it's um I don't know
sustainable to have I think there's a
lot of people who would vote for Sanders
but would never vote for Bloomberg and
vice versa I think one party all right
thank you so much for the call great to
hear from you hope to hear from you
again again if you're just joining us we
are taking live calls anybody can call
six one seven eight three zero four
seven five zero let me say thank you to
Kurt Hoffman who has signed up for a
website membership getting us to 16 16
out of 20 20 is the goal I also want to
say thank you to oh no there's nothing
else nobody else to think on Twitch let
me see here call so Hasan is busy as son
is busy so I not able to talk to his son
in the immediate let's go to let's go to
Chris from Oregon Chris from Oregon who
we haven't heard from since August Chris
what's going on hello David yes
go ahead Chris we can hear you fine
Chris go right ahead
hmm all right we lost Chris let's go to
our caller from the 978 area code call
her from 9 7 8 what's your name where
you calling from hey David my name is
Ryan I'm calling from Peabody mess love
Peabody go ahead
I was curious I went to a recent peat
rally I've been seeing he's actually
been blooming in Iowa and New Hampshire
now recently of California what do you
think his his presence within the top 3
will affect their numbers so let's look
at that I know about the Iowa numbers
but let me just get up to speed by
looking at the ones you just talked
about so Iowa indeed Budaj edge is
leading in the latest Monmouth poll but
not ahead in the latest Quinnipiac poll
so he may he may be up to something in
Iowa
what were the other states you mentioned
uh California he went from I believe it
was 8 up to 14 and now in New Hampshire
he is third at 14 behind Warren by just
one point so I don't see any 14 for
Budaj edge in California I see 9 in the
latest NPR poll but maybe that's a newer
one that hasn't yet made it unto Real
Clear Politics okay and then you
Hampshire was the other one let me just
I just want to get all the numbers New
Hampshire he is indeed polling 15 which
hasn't been basically tied for second
place with two other people or you could
say in third place so here's the thing
we actually talked about this on my
bonus show today I don't think that this
is necessarily evidence that Peabody
Judge is going to have the wide appeal
that some of his followers believe that
he is going to have but it is very clear
that in some parts of the country
he is getting at least enough support to
justify staying in this thing where is a
lot of the other people who
running really have to get out like it's
time to go for a lot of the other people
that are running people who to judge now
he can justify staying in this thing for
the long run and maybe he will actually
win a state or two but I don't know that
it's gonna go well beyond that okay oh
just curious on your take on the the
recent polling of course well it's my
pleasure to give you my take oh thank
you appreciate it
to you soon thank you we are taking
phone calls at six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty the number is in
the live stream title anybody can call
in and many people are let's go next to
you know I talked to James from Long
Island very recently but I'll just go to
him because he had some interesting
things to say last time James from Long
Island what's going on hey David first
of all I love the sweater just got to
say that thank you I appreciate that
it's a bathrobe II so I did yeah I just
had a question about health care right
so I'm only recently getting into the
point where I can feasibly like uphold a
conversation or an argument about health
care okay generally I can I can make the
are the moral argument easily I don't
think anybody should have to be burdened
financially by their health issues rum
and I can generally make the argument
that socialized not a socialized system
but a national health insurance system
is much cheaper than the system that we
have here in America um but I just
wanted to get your take because I
haven't done the research on this court
but I had the take brought up to me that
wait times would increase substantially
if we were to move to such a system like
that when I brought on Canada but that's
that's my question I'm asking you I
didn't have a argument to effect them
they just said oh if you look at Canada
they have wait times that are crazy long
that are much worse than us so I just
didn't well if no one is asserting why
they think that would happen you don't
have much to defend right I mean it's a
if someone just says wait times would go
up and they don't tell you why then it's
like well tell me tell me exactly why
wait times would go up but now usually
let's think ahead let's like let's
actually play it out sometimes what what
people will say is wait times will go up
because once healthcare is free people
are going to get everything done rather
than things they might not be doing now
because they can't afford it which is
crazy so there's kind of two answers to
that one is why are we satisfied with a
situation where people are opting not to
get procedures done because they can't
afford them and that's immoral but then
on the other side of that people don't
get medical treatment for fun in fact
most people live a life that hopefully
allows them to avoid medical treatment
and the idea that as soon as healthcare
is quote free at the point of service
everybody's gonna go get optional things
done it's it's ridiculous
it's just a ridiculous argument at its
face I think perhaps a better way to
frame my confusion is just the
straight-up ask you would would like
what would the effect be on wait times
for certain surgeries that aren't like
emergency is where they need to happen
right away yeah so there's no question
there's no question that it's possible
that for non-emergency surgery depending
on where you live you might have to wait
a little bit longer than you do now in
other areas it could actually
restructure the system so that the you
actually get a treatment faster but the
point is in all of the countries people
point to nobody is waiting too long for
emergency care and so when we think
about restructuring the entire system
reducing its cost increasing its
efficiency eliminating medical
bankruptcy eliminating people who say I
need X but I can't do it because I can't
afford it if you have to wait a little
longer for an optional procedure is that
not a fair trade to make I would agree
with that information in mind yum I just
wonder
I would like so I've heard people like
Steven Crowder say that oh because of
the system and the wait times that
family members of his have died or and
I'm just wondering like whether this
each one system over the other would
cause delays in such care to be like
devastating in that and tragic in that
sense listen people died in medical
treatment all over the world for a lot
of different reasons and it's really not
a good idea to be allowed to be pulled
into alleged anecdotal stories to make
policy based on that we don't make
policy based on anecdotal stories we
make policy in other ways and more adult
ways I would just refuse to even get
sucked into that okay I think that's
fair and I apologize for even bringing
up steven crowder on their own oh that's
okay it's totally allowed we're not
gonna do anything you know there's
there's some youtubers who if someone is
brought up whose name they don't like
they will later go out and remove the
mention of that person's name from the
clip I'm not gonna do that I can assure
you I remember watching a certain clip
of yours about that and I won't name
drop that person either but but you
would be allowed all right James from
Long Island thanks for the call thank
you so much thank you very good if
you're just joining us we we all had a
good time retweeting one of my recent
tweets at D Pakman it slowed down it's
up to 182 retweets but if you retweet it
you will see that retweet take place
live on screen which you might be
interested in a thanks to RJ CA for
cheering 100 bits I appreciate that I
also want to say thanks to Larry Shafer
for signing up for a new membership
Aaron Yoast for signing up for a new
membership Sara Steinberg for signing up
for a new membership that is three more
memberships on the website getting us up
to 19 we are just one away from 20 which
will guarantee guarantee write it in
your calendar or something
another stream this week okay six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
is the number if you want to talk to me
let's go next to our caller from the
four eight zero area code which if I
recall correctly is that is that Arizona
is it too son maybe um hello David this
is Alan Sachs yeah I was living in
Scottsdale Arizona but now I live in New
Jersey
oh alright well that's a very different
story and they're just like to thank you
for taking my call and apologize last
time I was not prepared but this time I
am prepared and I'd like to say I love
the YouTube streams and keep up the
YouTube live streams for the impeachment
hearings we will tomorrow at 10 a.m. yes
okay my question is are you familiar
with nate silver in 538 because I've
been listening to their podcast I am
familiar with nate silver and the
website although i've never heard the
podcast i'm so the last couple podcasts
basically they've been they've started
reaching a conclusion that the electoral
college isn't necessarily going to help
republicans high turnout isn't
necessarily going to help democrats
they've kind of thrown out commits
because i've i got a political science
undergraduate degree in tucson at
University of Arizona and I mean I
pretty much agree with everything you
say but just a 538 people there last
couple podcasts have really been saying
that you know high turnout could help
Trump you know let's say they were
saying high turnout in you know rural
areas or the electoral college isn't
necessarily gonna hurt the Democrats so
sure but so listen to the the way or so
if there's high turnout
disproportionately in rural areas it
might help Trump well are we expecting
higher than normal turnout in rural
areas with an unpopular president I mean
yes it could happen and if it did it
wouldn't be good for the Democrat but
until we have a reason to think that's
going to happen I don't know that we
necessarily consider in fact the other
example was the Electoral College won't
necessarily help the Republic
but historically typically it does it's
never to my knowledge helped a Democrat
become president who didn't win the
popular vote and there are you know
numerous examples of where it helped
Republicans who didn't win the popular
vote become president anyway so you know
when you add words like necessarily and
all of these others it almost sounds
like they're trying to be interesting
about things that are like a maybe
oh whoa we've just got hosted by destiny
destiny is hosting us to 3557 viewers
that is stunning isn't it yeah Wow
destiny I mean I've seen you talk about
it but otherwise yeah I mean I used to
love the 538 people but now I kind of
think like they're kind of doing the
both sides thing where they want to you
know they don't want because now they're
part of ABC News so they don't want to
say they want to be interesting they
don't want to just repeat the
conventional wisdom that yes I think
you're absolutely potentially right on
that alright thank you for the call very
much appreciate it and the good
preparation welcome to everybody who's
joining from Stephen destiny bunnell the
second stream welcome if you've never
been here I hope you will enjoy it right
now we are in what we call the live
phone calls phase of the evening we've
already talked about Donald Trump's very
very dilated eyes despite very bright
lights and we looked at video of him
looking mmm kind of like on Downer's we
looked at some polling we retweeted a
tweet of mine I'll play the video for
you in case people are wondering what
it's all done drank a lot of water a lot
of water fish are not this hydrated look
he's always taking [ __ ] look throughout
the hearing took slugs on the treadmill
it's amazing it's like a medical side a
medical sized water bottle yes indeed
okay let's go to our next caller if you
want to call in and I know that this is
risky because we're being hosted by
destiny right now but if you want to
call in the number is in the title six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty I will go to another caller from
the six one two area code our second six
one two caller of
evening hello ever did with me yes it is
hey this is Jonathan I'm in Minneapolis
hey how are you I'm good thanks man how
are you good
so thanks for taking my call so I was I
was just kind of thinking about this and
I actually posted this on your on your
video that discusses about whether
Warren or Sanders should drop out right
okay so what I was wondering and I think
about it so and I don't know the exact
numbers but I think your your point I
think is is interesting that if say
Sanders voters have as their second
choice X candidate and Warren voters
have as their second choice say Biden
okay then if Sanders brought so Sanders
drops out then what you're saying I
think it's valid is that only so many
voters who declared that their second
choice is the other candidate so in this
case if Sanders drops out it's Warren
but there's more for Biden yeah and
that's not really a huge advantage right
that's not a huge huge advantage for
that other candidate to drop out right
but what I'm wondering is what about the
other and I posted as hard money here on
the Facebook page what if like what
about the others say 55 percent or 50
percent of those voters right so what's
who's to assume and I'm just thinking
out loud I'm just kind of kind of figure
this out who is to assume that those
other fifty whatever plus percent of
those voters I haven't picked a second
choice or whose second choice might be
somebody else would then actually
gravitate towards either Sanders or
Warren whichever one doesn't drop out I
mean I I understand the question I don't
I mean it's it's speculative and I don't
know the answer and I don't know how we
would go about figuring that yeah and
that's kind of what I'm trying to think
about because I feel like you know
anecdotally I feel like most
progressives and in my community and as
people I talk to I mean most people are
saying you know what I'll take Sanders
or Warren yeah because I feel like
that's the strongest you know it's the
strongest progressive we're gonna have I
mean if anything if either of them are
our president we're talking about the
most progressive president since FDR not
more so
correct so most progressives would say
you know what even though it's
interesting that the polls show like
Biden as a second choice but at the end
of the day when push comes to shove you
know if Sanders stepped down I would for
sure and I could say any totally I think
a lot of progressives for sure I mean
you certainly would I you know listen to
your show every day I'm sure you would
be happy to support war and if Sanders
knocked out or vice-versa
certainly so anyway it obviously the
speculation but it's something to think
about because I feel like there's still
so many voters out there that you know
haven't reported their second choice and
or you know cuz there's fifty five
percent of voters in that poll that
haven't reported their second choice at
all I did not see that but I will look
at it and over certainly report back to
you okay cool thanks for taking my call
all right very much appreciate it thank
you very very much
thanks again to everybody joining from
the Destiny hosting I want to say thanks
to as Ron who has subscribed for two
months with twitch prime with the
message be nice and on that note I've
got a run I'm making dinner this evening
let's raid someone who has no idea who I
am but is a chess streamer I sometimes
watch just because a reaction will be
funny let's raid Alexandra botas this
will be a very very funny thing I can't
imagine what she will think about being
raided by David Pakman we rated Hikaru
Nakamura another chess streamer i watch
and he had no clue who I was the chat
devolved into politics which he didn't
like and he said I'm not trying to do
politics and it was fun and good times
to be had by all so let's do it
join me tomorrow 10:00 a.m. maybe for
you fine folks I'll even start like a
half hour early 10:00 a.m. Eastern time
for the impeachment hearings